hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
orphan black we got to meet a brand-new
clone we got to learn a lot more about
Sarah's like preseason one and the Helen
upper lethean plot just got really
really disturbing I would however like
to dedicate this video to the memory of
Ainsley so if you're finding me for the
first time I'm doing videos each week
for orphan black season - be sure to
subscribe to get everything I know a lot
of you in international countries
sometimes have to wait to watch the
episodes so don't worry these will
always be here so let's break a leg and
talk about our top 5 moments careful for
spoilers from episode 3 if you haven't
seen it yet but here we go number 5 art
finds the proletheans it seems like
every time art and Angela have a scene
together she invokes Beth she's just
trying to guilt him into resuming the
mystery of the clones and it looks like
she was successful I'm really hoping
that he ends up saving Helena and
because Gracie seems like she's the only
prolethean on the inside that's not you
know 100% down with making Helena the
new sister wife I'm hoping that she ends
up helping art number 4 Alison falls off
the stage poor blood ties was doomed
before it ever began watch that first
step it's a drop I love how somatically
the plot of the play works so well with
Alison's real life you know Aynsley
clone club drama no surprise that she
shotgunned a lot of pills and booze
beforehand let me know if you actually
thought that she was gonna react like
that on stage or if you thought she was
just you know pull some great
performance out of her but Tatiana
maslany in real life if she had been
performing that say like on Broadway
plywood had just pulled something out of
her button won an Emmy that's how
amazing she is it's so surreal watching
Alison it's an actor Tatiana maslany
performing a character Alison who's
performing a play bullet eyes and even
though Alison was supposed to collapse
under the pressure the whole thing was
just amazing we seriously need to make
sure that Tatiana maslany wins the Emmy
this year number three meet your new
clone
Jennifer the body that was going
on with the Cosima Delphine story this
week was so hard to watch did you notice
the way that she reacted whenever they
were dissecting Jennifer you know after
all the tapes and surgery it was like
she had to watch her own slow gruesome
death it's a real testament to how
disturbing it was that the show just
does an amazing job of putting you in
her perspective who else laughed just a
little bit whenever she told Delphine
not to be a and just tell her the
truth
even though the whole moment was just
very somber it was a very depressing
moment because they had been watching
Jennifer wither away in front of them
in case you missed it too they
identified that the autoimmune disease
that was affecting Jennifer as well as
Katya essentially started in the uterus
so any of the clones that are infertile
right now potentially have this same
issue that's going to be happening very
very soon to them that includes Rachel
Cosima and we're not quite sure about
Helena yet but because of the
interesting nature of her biology I
think we can assume that she's probably
fertile Jennifer was the first clone to
exhibit symptoms of this autoimmune
disease and in the timeline of the
episode she basically died three days
ago
number two the proletheans force Helena
to marry Henrik the show hasn't been
super clear on the technicalities of
prolethean marriage but I bet that
Henrik has been bound to multiple women
and in an episode where we had to watch
Jennifer degenerate and then get this
ected on the table I feel like this
Helena plot was way more disturbing did
anyone else scream at their TV whenever
he was carrying her down that hallway I
really hope that Gracie ends up helping
her out because you know even if it's
not altruistic I feel like any kind of
help would be a blessing speaking of
which it seems like based on Hendricks
instruments in the war of creation
speech the proletheans will be the crazy
group this season that will just
escalate things out of control I feel
like it's easier to trust someone like
leekie because he's operating from a
place of pure science which is all about
reliability imprecision you know he's
very evil but you can predict what he
might do because he's coming from a
place of logic the proletheans on the
other hand seem like they just twist any
situation to meet their needs you know
and as long as it's in God's name
anything goes it seems like they're
gonna be starting some fires this season
so keep your eyes peeled on them and my
number 1 moment meet Cal your dad did
anyone else have that moment when you
first saw him that you just thought of
Dario from Game of Thrones once he and
Sarah started to work through their
relationship and the WTF reveal of cure
being his daughter I really did enjoy
his character though it's a little
strange hearing him with an American
accent but I can't wait to see where his
story goes I'm guessing he'll just stay
part of that Sarah plot but every once
in a while different clones stories will
overlap so we could get some Cal Allison
scenes or some Cal Cosima depending on
where the season goes I know Sarah
really wants him to rub off on Kira I
feel like that's gonna happen
it seems like Kira is just like a sponge
she just absorbs everyone around her
she's just so intuitive she's almost
like a you know a fully grown adult in a
little child's body did anyone else
Specht him to be a dead shot with that
rifle though it just killed Daniel you
know until the whole car crash thing I
kind of thought her story we get folded
into Casillas back at the lab we did see
a bunch of mrs. s scenes and the teaser
for episode 4 so I wonder if it was her
that crashed into that car but now it's
your turn let me know below in the
comments what was your favorite moment
and who is your favorite clone this week
it's kind of hard to pick between
moments you know obviously meeting Cal
meeting cares fathers just a huge deal
and what's happening to helm is just so
horrible but I will say that my favorite
clone this week was definitely Jennifer
overall I gave the episode an a-minus
for doing such a good job of introducing
this new Cal wrinkle into the plot as
well as the new character Jennifer I
don't know how many episodes Cal is
gonna be in but I really hope he
survives to season 3 the really good
thing about orphan black and his other
show Game of Thrones is that they don't
shoot at the same time so even though he
was upgraded to a cast regular for
season 5 of Game of Thrones he can still
film episodes of orphan black season 3
if it ends up getting renewed speaking
of actors though I feel like we're all
in agreement that Tatiana maslany is a
goddess on this show but every time she
introduces a new clone or a new
character I'm always just amazed by what
she brings to the table just all the
different nuances and tics that all the
clones have is just mind-boggling it's
so amazing that she can juggle all these
things in her head I feel like if you
asked her to she could just sit in a
room and do all the clones having a
conversation with themselves you know
just seamlessly jumping in and out of
different characters like a one-person
clone Club stage-play blood ties style
Alison should take some notes because
the subplots in each of these new
episodes has kept me so engaged I've
actually started to kind of forget a
little bit about the over plot you know
the Project Lead a mystery as well as
the end game of the proletheans and
what's going on with leekie it really is
just a testament to the show that it can
get so complex and stay so interesting
without getting out of control
but at this point are we even sure we
know what the proletheans would do with
another Kyra if Helena could really get
pregnant we know that leekie is trying
to patent human DNA you know they're
just a mega corporation trying to get
rich even if the proletheans don't care
about money it seems like they're and
result will end up being the same though
just a bunch of homogenized humans made
in whatever they consider to be their
perfect image I wonder if in that
scenario everyone on the planet would
just get married to each other and
big creepy binding ceremony yikes but
let me know what your final thoughts are
on the episode as well as the new kal
character I really can't wait to see
where they take that so it's gonna be
really interesting
my next orphan black video will post
after episode for us be sure to
subscribe to get it
tomorrow will be all about Game of
Thrones as per usual so right now click
here to get last week's video for orphan
black and click here to catch up on Game
of Thrones thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you